and Hillary Clinton's 2016 campaign
manager Robby Mook joins us now he's
currently president of the House
Democrats political action committee
Robbie good morning yeah thanks for
having me I'm assuming you stayed up all
late last night to watch the debate I
did a little bit later than I expected a
little bit yeah no doubt last night to
you as somebody who can beat Donald
Trump in 2020 yeah what stood out to me
was this chasm really opened up in the
party you know it wasn't it wasn't that
it wasn't that evident in the first bait
there are two camps here and they're
arguing one says got to be big got to be
bold the other saying whoa whoa whoa
whoa what do you see one camp is capable
of beating Trump in 2020 and the other
camp not yeah
look I see one camp as more capable of
winning a primary contest basically you
know with with big ideas big bold ideas
that's what primary can it's like I
think there's a very good point though
if the debate in the general election is
about whether you get to keep your
private health insurance yes that's
taking an issue that is a strength for
our party right now and potentially
turning it into a voter about was the
warning shield concern that was a
warning shot fired by multiple moderate
candidates last night basically saying
we lose if you do this yeah and I look
and I think we need to we need to let
this play out we need to let people talk
but I think both sides have a really
good point and it's gonna be up to the
voters to choose this ya know yeah if
you were managing one of these campaigns
and the goal was to beat Joe Biden who
right now is sitting the top of the
polls how would you do it well if last
night's are textbook okay two two things
revenues first of all the structure of
the debate kind of hit the candidates
off each other so this is so the the
format promotes conflict essentially
definitely promote and the big question
and so Kansas are gonna go after Biden
probably and the question for Biden is
you know if he has maybe one or two
people coming after him you can manage
that
what if six candidates are coming after
him that's a lot to handle what do to
make a difference in the polls right now
he's way ahead yeah look at some point
people need to win states you know we're
very focused on these national polls
which by the way are meaningless and
really Iowa New Hampshire you know we
haven't been talking a lot about that
they're really important they're the
first contest so I I'm looking at what
candidates have the best operation on
the ground and a message and
you know a rationale for the candidacy
that really sustains and supports that
take Warren she's got a great operation
in Iowa and I when I was watching that
listen I was trying to think if I were
in Iowa activists you know I think there
was a lot to rally around there so she's
had she's had momentum and major Garrett
suggested in our first era our that
essentially that if you look at last
night than Bernie and Warren kind of
tied but in fact that's a loss for
Bernie do you think that so yeah it was
really interesting because I do think
they need some of what each other has
you know and Warren definitely needs to
take some away from Bernie they clearly
made a decision
individually I assume to not go after
each other but at some point we may see
that they need to engage and take away
and and look Biden to like Biden has
some that he needs stake Harris tonight
has got to win more african-american
voters away from Biden so we might see
those sparks fly again out of the entire
panel last night it seemed as though
everyone got their shot in who do you
think is going to drop out at this point
who will make it to the next leg I think
a lot of that's about money so a lot of
these candidates frankly to get on that
debate stage and qualifier having to
spend money to raise money they're
having to get a lot of donors and that
can get very expensive
so I do think potentially in the early
fall some people will just have to face
the music
other candidates have a nest egg
particularly some of these senators who
could transfer money and they can
probably stay in through Iowa but if
you're not in the next debate if because
you don't have enough donors how are you
getting the lift to grow a campaign
organization
I thought crunch time is coming in soon
yeah I think it's coming if you're not
in that next debate how do you get your
message out it's really interesting what
you said at the top with the two camps
and you seem to suggest that the
progressive camp can win in the
primaries but not necessarily in the
general and our camp can win in the
general but but not on the primaries how
do the Democrats go forward with that
kind of split this is a classic tension
in every single presidential race what
happened in 2016 it's what happened in
2012 we saw Romney getting pushed to the
right and so on it definitely was an
issue in 2016 look I think any of these
candidates can win against Trump I think
there are outstanding factors like the
economy they're enormous ly important
what I do worry about is we won the 2018
election on health care and on this tax
bill and if those things are flipped
where we might raise people's taxes
where where people's hell
insurance where they're uncertain about
what will happen with their health
insurance that could be a problem for us
and we and with them we just have to
navigate that Republicans are good at
that spinning they'll see that weakness
and absolutely they always want to turn
you your strength into your weakness
yeah surely who did judge said last he
said last night they'll call us they'll
call us socialists no matter what and
and he's right about that and that's why
I think like trying to predict the
general election isn't the right way to
do this let's see who builds a sound
campaign operation you know that matters
too don't call it this early yeah and
don't and don't also try to I thought
Buddha jij had such a good point don't
try to put these artificial labels on
people let's just let's let the voters
argue this out amongst themselves and
high turnouts a good thing the more
people that participate in the primary
the more that electorate will look like
the general electorate the better so
then quickly back to question one you
think they all still have a chance to
beat Trump in 2020 definitely I mean
let's be clear I think sometimes a
little bit more energy than others but
you know III don't like this game of you
know a general election quickly or more
people registering to vote yeah yeah
we're seeing I mean initial things
initial data I've seen there there is
good registration I think you're gonna
see that surge early next year okay well
a very vigorous debate last night Robin
look thank you so much for being with us
thanks